io ho cominciato
a presto a fare
scelte importanti
sono sempre sempre stato
stato del mare delle barche sempre i
miei genitori si ricordano che mi
lasciavano seduto sulle banchine dei
posti di vacanza dove andavamo e io
rimanevo un'ora due ore a guardare le
barche la gente che usciva il mare e la
gente che si preparava per fare una
regata è il ricordo che ho io non è
questo il ricordo che io però è nelle
sensazioni che provavano ancora oggi
quando cammino sulle banchine cammino
spesso sulle banchine dei porti un po in
tutto il mondo quella sensazione la
provo quell'odore me lo ricordo e mi
sento sempre un po marinaio anche se
purtroppo il ragioni del mio lavoro
navigo sempre meno sulla mia di barca le
prima scelta che ho dovuto fare era
dovuto proprio questa passione che
invece non avevo scelto mi ci sono
trovato ma in ragione di questa passione
ero un adolescente ho dovuto scegliere
se continuare a frequentare il gruppo
degli amici con cui ero cresciuto io
vengo da bologna non c'erano molti
appassionati di mare e quindi parlare
delle cose che in verità mi
interessavano relativamente o rischiare
di essere escluso da questo gruppo e
incontrare qualcuno che avesse una
passione la passione per il mare in
comune con me sembra una scelta da poco
ma quando tu sei adolescente tutti
essere incluso in un gruppo non vuoi
essere escluso quindi l'importanza della
passione è stata evidente perché ho
scelto di cercare qualcuno con cui
condividere la passione i sabati invece
di passarli in giro in vespa sui colli
bolognesi o davanti al bar insieme agli
amici molto spesso andavo al mare
prendevamo il treno e davamo una mano a
farle delle regate a pulire le barche ho
tutto quello che mi potesse tenere a
contatto col mare
ripeto sembra una scelta banale ma
quando ai 14 anni non lo è
io tornavo dalla mia compagnia e veniva
un po
preso in giro non ho mai avuto problemi
di socializzazione questo non voglio
dire questo però è quella strana
sensazione in cui loro ti guardano come
una cosa un po strana ma come ci hai
abbandonato non sei più uno dei nostri
ha dei nuovi amici frase di queste ne ho
sentite molto sempre in ragione di
questa grande passione ho cominciato a
un po a guidare la mia la mia esistenza
è una cosa scuro fino dal ragazzo sono
stato abbastanza concentrato crescendo
in realtà ho preso una decisione non ho
fatto una scelta ma ho preso una
decisione che è stata quella di studiare
giurisprudenza sono nato sono cresciuto
in un ambiente un po conservatore
diciamo così per cui sembrava che solo
le professioni intellettuali fossero
degni e di dignità professionale
in realtà io sapevo che non era così ma
in quel caso ho deciso non ho scelto ho
deciso di fare giurisprudenza
ascoltando quello che le persone intorno
a me mi dicevano e sentendo un po di
vivendo quella pressione di cui abbiamo
sentito parlare anche oggi e quindi la
mia decisione è stato di studiare ma
quando è stato il momento di iniziare a
lavorare
ho iniziato a lavorare in uno studio
legale e in quel caso invece ho scelto
contro i pareri di tutti ho scelto
invece di andare a lavorare nello studio
in cui sarei entrato senza problemi
perché amici di amici mi avrebbero
coccolato e fatto crescere
professionalmente occupandomi di diritto
civile
ho scelto in maniera abbastanza forte e
ho scelto di occuparmi di materia e
l'onta che non mi avevano neanche
insegnato all'università di diritto
d'autore di diritto dello spettacolo e
di tutela della proprietà intellettuale
in particolare nella tutela del
copyright su internet perché almeno in
quel modo non avevo scelto di fare quel
lavoro avevo deciso di farlo ma in quel
modo almeno mi occupavo di cose che
erano abbastanza tangente a quelle altre
mie passioni
non sapevo che potrebbe potuto fare
l'avvocato dello yachting che poi ho
scoperto però avevo già preso atto tra
strada
e quindi mi sono occupato di queste
materie
occupandomi di queste materie non è
stato occuparmi di queste materie non è
stato casuale
in realtà tutto è nato dall'incontro con
una persona estremamente speciale è
tutta la mia vita è costellata da scelte
legate a persone questa persona che oggi
non c'è più è stato un maestro
incredibile per me che ho vissuto sei
anni con questo uomo atto hanno scusate
con questo uomo che mi ha reso quello
che sono oggi dal punto di vista umano
più che professionale
un uomo con un'etica uno spessore
intellettuale altissimo un avvocato che
però si prendeva gioco del mondo degli
avvocati e avevo capito che la mia
scelta era stata quella giusta ma avevo
scelto la persona ancora prima del
lavoro e con questa persona
lui si può essere me stesso facendo un
lavoro che ancora una volta avevo deciso
di fare ma non era veramente quello che
volevo fare
dopo questa esperienza ho cominciato
però a capire che era come se avessi una
barca perfetta per fare il giro del
mondo e stessi navigando a palombina
avanti e indietro solo di giorno
mettendo l'ancora appena veniva buio mi
sentivo veramente un pochino un pochino
con le vele tarpate diciamo e capii che
era il momento di prendere in mano di
nuovo la mia esistenza e di guidarla
dove era giusto fare
io uso spesso una metafora dopo avere
fatto queste scelte mi viene sempre più
facile farla in realtà io nel momento in
cui devo scegliere praticamente come
guidare la mia esistenza
improvvisamente pulendo il parabrezza
vedendo la scelta da fare
chiara illuminata ben asfaltata di e
prenderla perché mi sono reso conto che
allenato da movimento non vi racconto
tutte le scelte però allenato dalle
scelte che ho fatto mi sono reso conto
che in realtà la parte difficile è
decidere di scegliere non è scegliere
noi nel momento in cui decidiamo di
scegliere dentro di noi sappiamo già
quello che vogliamo fare noi guidiamo
questa questa macchina della nostra vita
della nostra esistenza
piano piano guidandola il parabrezza si
riempie di detriti si sporca noi
smettiamo di vedere quindi non vediamo
la cosa giusta da fare ma probabilmente
per paura di vedere quella cosa lasciamo
il parabrezza sporco
la parte difficile decidere di andare a
pulire in quel momento ebbe la forza di
farlo su molto difficile perché ho
dovuto anche staccarmi da questa persona
di cui vi parlavo ho pulito il
parabrezza nella strada l'ho vista molto
chiara la strada era lì era illuminata
era saltata era segnalata c'erano
persone che mi indicavano dove andare
nel momento in cui ho pulito il
parabrezza ho avuto la forza di dirmi no
io voglio lavorare dove c'è il mare
voglio lavorare con le barche voglio
occuparmi di quello che veramente mi
piace difficilissimo perché la mia
carriera nello studio legale era già
avanzata e andava tra l'altro anche bene
ma sono riuscito a decidere contro tutto
e contro tutti ovviamente immaginate una
famiglia
al 15 o non faccio più l'avvocato vado a
lavorare con le barche perché non sapevo
neanche anche cosa fare in realtà gli
amici stessi ma lo feci decisi di andare
a vivere
scegliendo a lavorare scusate scegliendo
ancora una volta in maniera un po
atipica avrei potuto andare a lavorare
per le grandi società di brokerage di
intermediazione e vendita di superyacht
invece preso una decisione ancora una
volta che per tutti sembrava folle
decisi di andare a lavorare per una
piccolissima società che si trovava a
saint tropez in francia gestita da
titolare olandese ex windsurfista ex
istruttore di vela che ex imprenditore
dell'edilizia con cui però
immediatamente mi sono trovato benissimo
abbiamo iniziato il colloquio alle due
di pomeriggio alle dieci di sera stavamo
ancora parlando tutti mi guardavano
molto male quando dissi vabbeh lavorare
per questa mini società che non conosce
nessuno invece io avevo capito che con
questo uomo
avrei potuto fare qualcosa di veramente
importante per rendere la cosa ancora un
po più complessa e per tenermi allenato
nella scelta e nello stesso momento un
più deciso di andare a lavorare per
questa società e di andare a vivere in
francia saint tropez e che suona
benissimo ma provateci a vivere dodici
mesi all'anno d'inverno è veramente
complicato preso un'altra decisione non
ha soprattutto una scelta ho fatto molto
importante ho deciso di sposare mia
moglie che era che conoscevo da 60
giorni dopo 60 giorni ci conoscevamo gli
ho detto se io ti voglio sposare tra
l'altro per telefono lei australia
se no non è ancora una volta scelte e
persone importanti il fatto che sia più
dimostra che la scelta giusta
poi sono passati tantissimi anni e
prendo questa decisione vada in francia
inizia a lavorare come broker un sogno
cioè voi immaginate uno che lavorava in
uno studio legale s'alzava la mattina
non era neanche tanto quello che gli
piaceva 3 non avevamo sedi a milano ea
roma perugia roma milano bologna così
improvvisamente mi svegliavo la mattina
salivo su un tender metteva in moto
attraversava il golfo di saint tropez
uno dei più bei goffi del mediterraneo
andavo in ufficio ormeggiava entravano
in ufficio sul porto di saint tropez una
cosa meravigliosa
sono stati anni veramente veramente
molto belli però ancora una volta mi si
presenta tenendo il parabrezza sempre
abbastanza pulito
mi si presenta un'opportunità e faccia
una scelta decido di andare a montecarlo
dove mi avevano i posti che sono molto
meno di quello che suona vado a
montecarlo e mi offrono di rilanciare
una società di brokerage sul mercato
prendo al volo questa occasione
ancora una volta e per la seconda volta
comunicare la decisione alle persone
così importanti per me qui mi ero
affiancato e qui mi ero affidato è stato
molto più facile di quello che pensassi
perché le persone che ti vogliono bene
ti guardano negli occhi tutti i comuni
che la tua scelta
e loro ti dicono fai bene io preferisco
che tu sia felice e tu stia vicino a me
in tutti e due i casi mi è stato detto
così incazzati perché
però ce lo dicono veramente te lo dicono
sinceramente ti dicono mi fa girare le
scatole che tu te ne vada però fai bene
e questo è successo anche quella volta
la montecarlo se da un'altra cosa molto
importante nei decisa nei scelta nasce
il nostro figlio è appena nasce il
nostro figlio noi decidiamo che quello
non era il posto dove crescere un
bambino noi chiamavamo monaco la
chiamavamo truman villa un posto dove la
realtà fa fatica a penetrare e viene
tenuta molto bene al di fuori e quindi
di nuovo un'altra strada illuminata
tergicristallo parabrezza guardo cavoli
c'è una strada in questo caso devo dire
c'era la gente davanti faceva mettere
delle altre serve sì ma è così qui
proprio la gente si sdraiava per terra
piuttosto che farmela fare deciso
infatti di lasciare il mondo del
brokerage e della costa azzurra mondo
anche ricco dal punto di vista
retributivo tra l'altro le altre cose e
decido dopo saint tropez dopo montecarlo
divenire vivere ancora non solo
mia moglie ha vissuto tutta la vita
simile in tra l'altro quindi è l'eroe
lei che abbiamo seguito e vengo ad
ancona e vengo a lavorare in un
importantissimo cantiere navale che
conoscete tutti che si chiama crn che
faceva parte del gruppo ferretti in quel
momento il gruppo ferretti
era il gruppo numero uno al mondo però
lavorare in un cantiere per uno che
faceva il broker che un mondo in cui si
guadagna veramente molto bene tutto
molto scintillante da tutti veniva visto
come una retrocessione
quindi tutto dice ma sei matto cosa fai
in più il presidente amministratore
delegato del cantiere altra persona più
devo moltissimo veniva considerato da
tutta l'industria nautica un pazzo e
gotico che spaccava bicchieri quando
litigava con i dipendenti eccetera
io invece ho analizzato bene questa
situazione è un invece di vedere una
retrocessione in realtà io vedevo una
retrocarica c'è un po come nel rugby
nera b tu passi la palla indietro per
guadagnare territorio in avanti io
vedevo la possibilità di fare
un'esperienza all'interno di un cantiere
come una possibilità di crescita
incredibile al punto di vista della
conoscenza quando tu fai il lavoro del
broker o qualsiasi altro lavoro nel
mondo che oggi è il mio mondo grazie a
dio quello delle barche conoscere come è
costruito una barca è fondamentale
eccolo e farlo vicino ai migliori del
mondo perché c'erano i migliori
architetti del mondo i migliori anni in
genieri del mondo
era un'opportunità che altri non
vedevano è veramente li ho avuto
posizioni di di ogni tipo per me per non
farmelo fare eppure parabrezza lava per
meyer ha perso un lavaggio puliscono la
brezza la vedo la prendo decidiamo
veniamo ad ancona sono state anni ancora
una volta meravigliosi la persona che
tutti mi descrivevano come un drago
pericolosissimo è una persona cui devo
moltissimo di quello che ho fatto nel
mondo quel poco come quello che ho fatto
nel mondo della nautica qualsiasi cosa
sia
ne devo moltissimo moltissimo a lui
insieme in 67 anni abbiamo siamo
riusciti a fare del crn dell'ufficio
commerciale del crn in particolare che
da quello che dirigevo io lo dico senza
falsa modestia veramente una punta di
diamante noi abbiamo venduto 58 navi da
30 a 80 metri in cinque anni sono numeri
pazzeschi noi facciamo un lavoro in cui
le vendite si sono unità vendere quattro
navi all'anno e una cosa meravigliosa
noi abbiamo tutte 58 in cinque anni ma
ancora una volta detriti per un po di
tempo finto di non vedere non mi andava
più bene
il crn era un'entità a parte all'interno
del gruppo ferretti entra all'interno
della della grande realtà di gruppo e
invece di essere di cantiere navale che
io adoravo diventa più cosa più simile a
una fabbrica quindi una grande sperso
nalizzazione io passavo la maggior parte
del mio tempo a parlare di politiche e
dinamiche interne tra management gruppo
intragruppo cosa di questo genere non
parlano mai di barche era il 2010
fallivano tutti i cantieri nel mondo
lead in italia la nautica sembrava
cancellata era un si salvi chi può
il derby di nordi nautiche di naufragi
io decido insieme a un altro matto e di
fare qualcosa di nuovo e scelgo di
costituire un nuovo cantiere in cantiere
quando tutti i cantieri chiudevano
semplicemente su sulla base di un
intuizione e che oggi si è rivelata
valida che è quella che quei clienti di
quei clienti miliardari rimanevano
quelli veramente appassionati di barche
erano diventati meno ricchi non più
poveri e lo erano diventati
temporaneamente questo concetto tutti
entrati nel panico improvvisamente non
c'erano più ricchi nel mondo
questi erano ricchissimi un po meno di
prima noi abbiamo avuto questa
intuizione abbiamo puntato sul fatto che
quelli appassionati di barche cercavano
banche per andare veramente per mare si
erano stancati delle barche
tutti i gadget lumicini e abbiamo creato
in cantiere in cui prima di tutto
abbiamo ideato un prodotto che
somigliasse alle barche da lavoro quindi
ispirassero immediatamente forza fossero
costruite come barche da lavoro quindi
capaci di andare in tutti i posti del
mondo perché questa gente ne aveva
smesso di andare nei posti dove c'erano
troppi fari e cominciava a volere andare
grazie a dio in posti diversi perché
questi si radunano tutti negli stessi
posti ed è andata bene è stato un
successo fin dall'inizio
soprattutto perché abbiamo iniziato a
lavorare partendo dalla base
abbiamo dato importanza prima di tutte
le persone che le barche le costruivano
la nostra brochure prima brochure
riportava le foto e le parole dei nostri
operai non dei poeti tu uomo libero a
mera il mare e le foto della signora
portofino vestito la sera coi tacchi che
in barca non si mettono la de scarpe
però nelle pubblicità sono così ad
essere partiti da lì essere partiti da
chi le barche ne faceva è stata l'altra
chiave che oggi se voi guardate nel
mondo dell'advertising del lusso è molto
utilizzato stiamo parlando di diversi
diversi anni fa e il cantiere è oggi il
numero uno al mondo nel proprio segmento
abbiamo il secondi molto molto molto
distanti da noi ma la cosa mi rende più
orgoglioso è il fatto che i nostri
clienti consulenti dei nostri clienti
chiunque entra spessissimo definisce il
cantiere col sorriso la cosa che mi
rende mi rende molto felice è certamente
il successo che abbiamo avuto perché le
scelte non sono stato facile non sono
state facili per me perché mi era vicino
assolutamente ma il averle fatte molti
di voi ce l'hanno fatto lo sanno
nel momento in cui l'hai fatta ti giri e
13 ma perché non l'ho fatta prima
e questa è una cosa che non bisogna
dimenticare è difficile decidere ma nel
momento in cui si fa la scelta è la
scelta giusta
indipendentemente dagli esiti in questo
caso gli esiti sono stati buoni
molto buoni ma è stato facile
e bastato scegliere di farlo
[Musica]
[Applauso]